hello and welcome to this video playing
my way okay he plays this weird opening
under Sicilian I want to try that again
at this Bishop g5 stuff jack okay so we
have some sort of some sort of Smith
Maura with the bishop he and the Queen
on a five which is weird it weird for
both sides I guess okay so he probably
wants to wants to do some might be five
maybe since it's all about the dark
squares I can try to exploit them I try
not g6 to cover the dark squares maybe
this is true slow possible
and one day a three or something here
maybe
don't I just have a signal than it takes
and sorry then he takes any place 96's
what I'm trying to say you're
it's not not a lot of fun I know 97's
almost made it she gets the sir but then
I don't think there was anything this
was my idea getting the Queen's traded
he still has some compensation for sure
ninety-three that's 95 so I think he has
to trade even an hour maybe it not the
one I can take c4 is very likely just 90
x be a queen takes before
so really an alternative here don't see
it
hmm isn't that very impractical to thank
you for a long time why am I just blind
for not seeing any other player move I
really don't see another move I mean c4
is hanging
that's very strange
I thought 95 just wins apiece why isn't
this just winning a piece
okay I don't get it yeah I have Quincy
425f 6 which is really just a piece
tween age five maybe it's not really
dangerous at least not objectively
speaking Czech so he wants to take I
guess Queen f4 should be good covering
covering relevant dark squares check no
okay
so maybe just give five now Bishop d7
and so on
ok
okay see for some counter attack you I
Queen g5 yes this okay now then he's got
to check anyway check
check Oh didn't see that check don't
don't tell me that the sister some kind
of play for wireless would be just
utterly disgusting then it's got Luke g3
and kinda little nonsense just a piece
down for nothing but absolutely nothing
it's unbelievably Rocky III m we have
seven kings is six and IM can cover the
look at least dammit
you
check check check time warning check
check check check check check check
check okay so you cannot check again
threatening check check and take on g
tool and i really hope that this is
enough to win check just one check check
now my king is relatively safe okay wow
I was really scared in the middle of the
game light resides that was just a
complete pizza and then it got this is
just a piece for absolutely nothing and
then it got very scary slight got very
scary 85 is just probably nonsense be 60
in okay it's the same thing and the
computer is just giving like minus 3 of
course which computer will defend this
very simply but yeah I don't know maybe
I was okay but check it is like super
scary yeah yeah I was I was more afraid
of this but I wanted to go here we're
just working but I can go back this is
actually nothing yeah it's nothing I'm
threatening made at the rook hangs and
so this this so I wasn't I wasn't losing
I was closing here Queenie four winds
yeah this is a trap position to play
some play and such awkward stuff King
Edwin's but who cares Jack we never
would have believed 14 wide check and
here yeah check Jen Jen Jen winning
again check check check check check yeah
there's a ton of checks but he is
running out of them and down and now I
can coordinate in windows with the
material my d5 was bad I was pretty
shocked that he just gave the piece I
mean and it was
quite clearly not working at all I mean
he has to take on before which is
definitely compensation for wired with
this bishops with the bishop a dark
squared bishop in particular strong will
be very difficult for me to coordinate I
think here on white has full
compensation which is the grid I'm which
engine confirms that gives equal
disposition and this justice is the work
at all check your black just wins this
pollution yeah unless you're here
blunder and wow okay thanks for watching